okay so i've got a new segment could be
a one-time segment
i don't know but i'm calling it hot off
the press
the reason i'm calling it that i saw a
study that was published online
yesterday that uh
is a bit relevant it's a question that i
get a lot i'm not going to do a really
deep dive on the study but it is one of
those things where i saw it come up and
figure
hey i know several thousand people that
would like to hear about this so
the paper was called metabolic effects
of a prolonged very high dose
dietary fructose challenge in healthy
subjects
and it was published by smodgus at all
and like i said it was published
yesterday
now the purpose of the study here was to
investigate
basically what happens when we give
healthy people
really high doses of fructose for a
sustained kind of prolonged period of
time so they got 10 healthy subjects
they were 28 years old on average but a
big range it was 28 plus or minus 19.
that's a
pretty huge variability there and you
know that skews up
yeah yeah because it's not like they
have that many 11 year olds
yeah exactly um bmi on average was 22
and what they did was they gave them for
an eight week protocol they gave them
150 grams per day
of fructose that's a lot of fructose
and the reason i wanted to kind of
quickly report these findings is because
i have a lot of people who
who will ask me hey i really like fruit
but i'm reading on the internet that
fructose which is a you know one of the
predominant types of sugar in fruit
that's a misconception by the way a lot
of people think that all of the sugar
in fruit is fructose and that's not the
case but but it is uh
a fruit is a big source of fructose in
the diet
i think that's because in a lot of well
i may be about to talk
out of my ass i was going to say in a
lot of introductory nutrition classes
you learned that fructose is fruit sugar
right i don't know if that's taught in a
lot of classes that's what was taught in
my intro
introductory nutrition class so yeah i
assume that that's a somewhat common
thing
yeah people think of fructose and they
say oh that's the sugar from fruit
um and i mean table sugar and high
fructose corn syrup and like
well table sugar is 50 50 right sucrose
that's
yeah it's half glucose and half fructose
so we we get it all over the place but
people kind of connect it in their mind
to fruit and then by extension they
think
all fruit sugar is fructose and that's
not the case it's actually
a mixture of multiple simple sugars but
in any case
150 grams daily like i said i get a lot
of people who say eric i like fruit
i don't know anybody that likes fruit
this much that they're getting 150 daily
grams of fructose from their fruit
intake
unless like durian writer or freely the
banana girl are listening to us
exactly yeah i mean if so what's up yeah
i'd love to have you
um no but so could you do it
sure but the question would be why you
know so in any case
what i really like about this is um you
know it's a controlled intervention
where they really are pushing pretty
much the higher limit that you would
even
consider like feasibly obtaining in a
diet unless you're trying to prove a
point basically
um what they found like i said it was an
eight-week intervention
uh the people who they gave them this
high fructose
intake what they did was they they saw
that
there was lower intake of other dietary
sugars um to kind of compensate for that
not intentionally but it's just kind of
what happened and they did not really
increase their total daily energy intake
in response to this intervention they
basically just kind of shifted their
calories around
to accommodate it what they found was
that ectopic lipid deposition and
postprandial glycogen storage in the
liver and skeletal muscle
were not altered they found that um
this eight-week intervention of very
high fructose intake
was not associated with any meaningful
adverse metabolic consequences so
the big thing to keep in mind here is
that these people were at a pretty
stable energy intake they didn't see a
huge increase in total calories
body weight was slightly reduced but not
not to a major degree over the course of
the intervention
but basically what this study shows in a
nutshell is
if you're a young metabolically healthy
person
who is controlling your overall energy
intake and maintaining your body weight
at a relatively stable spot
fructose intakes even up to this really
high number of 150 grams a day
they really don't seem to be as
catastrophic as you might believe when
it comes to these different metabolic
outcomes so
um good news for the people who like
fruit
and just to put that in perspective you
know it's not exactly 50 50 but
i think high fructose corn syrup and a
lot of beverages is like what 55-45
so putting that those numbers in
perspective i mean we're talking about
like
getting nearly 300 grams of sugar per
day from soft drinks
to match this level of fructose intake
so this is about as high as anyone
worried about their health would ever
possibly
approach even if they had really high
fruit intake and
the takeaway from the study is as long
as you've got all your ducks in a row
for your diet
in terms of making sure your energy
balance is appropriate
turns out not that bad it's good to hear